how you doing people
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for april 1st
2021 and as always click that subscribe
button
and tap that notification bell so that
you see our videos in your feed
and before we get to anything else i
just want to uh quickly say i did a
little thinking last night
and i've decided that everything i've
been saying on this show
is wrong i've decided to become woke
i've decided that i'm going to become an
anti-racist
i've decided that aoc is smart
i've decided that socialism and
communism
are the best way forward and i've
decided to actively participate in the
destruction of the united states and i
hope that
you guys will join me in that that will
be the focus
of the reuben report going forward and
my life's work because
i believe that identity politics is good
i believe that critical race theory is
just and i believe that we should judge
people
on the color of their skin not the
content
of their character happy april fools
everybody
oh did you hear that crack that was a
crack all right people uh we are doing a
q
a today we got about 100 questions at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh before we get to that i'm going to do
one quick story the wokesters are coming
for
uh barack obama i knew they were coming
for him i've been warning you barry
but they're really coming for you i've
been saying they're going to burn down
his library because he
you know ran against gay marriage first
time around but it's even worse
we'll get to that in a moment before we
do it though i want to talk to you guys
about built
bar not bill barr built bar
you know it's not often that you get to
put the words healthy and delicious in
the same sentence together so if you've
been struggling to keep that new year's
resolution to get healthier
i'm about to bring you some really good
news it's called built bar
and it's the rare item of food that's
both healthy and
delicious biltbar is high in protein and
fiber
low in calories and carbs each bar
contains between 110 and 160 calories up
to 20 grams of protein
and only three to five net carbs so you
can do this on keto
if you'd like and meanwhile it's made
with real chocolate and tastes amazing
this is the kind of snack that's going
to allow you to lose or maintain weight
while indulging in something delicious
and that's always a welcome change built
bar has a ton of amazing flavors like
caramel brownie cookies and cream peanut
butter mint brownie and a lot more
i know that the reuben report community
has been loving them we get people
commenting all the time
don't give up on your resolution built
bar is the answer go to builtbar.com and
use promo code ruben to get 15
off your next order use promo code ruben
for 15
off at builtbar.com i feel like i have
to apologize to a few of you who may
have thought i was being serious for
those 30 seconds i i am a classically
trained actor i did take
acting classes for like four months back
in
when was that about 2004. actually
little known fact
uh melissa rausch who plays bernadette
or played bernadette in big bang theory
she was a friend of mine from stand-up
years but we took acting classes
together there's a little something for
you i took him for about four minutes
couldn't couldn't take it actors are
pretty
unbearable although i love melissa all
right so we're gonna do one story here
and then roll right into the q
a and we got a ton of good questions and
they're sort of all over the map which
i've been trying to you know break it up
from just purely political stuff
uh so this is just great this story
because it's just such a perfect example
of how the woke
are only here to destroy they are not
here to create
this is not a political movement meaning
they're going to try to build good
institutions
they are here to burn everything down
and that's it people
even if they're trying to convince you
otherwise uh activists
in chicago are protesting the renaming
of a chicago school
because barack obama is a quote
oppressor
yeah that's right uh this is from fox
news wacogans
i think i got the pronunciation right
there board of education met
tuesday evening to debate renaming
thomas jefferson middle school
and daniel webster middle school after
it was decided that historical figures
either owned slaves or supported slavery
one of the top contenders for thomas
jefferson middle school's new
name is that of the first black
president barack obama
and former first lady michelle but that
name is drawing the ire of
immigration activists and some in the
latino community
activists stage a protest outside the
board meeting
tuesday we've got a quote here from
edgar castellanos
who's a school board member of district
60
he said i will not be part of renaming a
school after someone who did not and
does not represent
the undocumented community fox news went
on to say the obama administration
deported 1.18
1.18 million people in three years and
under trump about 800
000 were deported in the first three
years so barack obama
did deport more illegal people than
scary orange man this is just a fact now
i've been warning you guys
and trying to hint to the few and
increasingly less increasingly less uh
amount of sane liberals that they're
going to destroy everything and it was
obvious to me
if the progressives of today are here to
destroy everything they will destroy
everything of the past so
20 years from now the progressives of 20
years from now will want to destroy
whatever it is that aoc and ilhan omar
and the rest of these ridiculous people
are trying to accomplish
so of course when barack obama's library
goes up they're going to say he was
against gay marriage and if
they won't have any context of time that
that took place in or
people evolving politically or
religiously or philosophically or
whatever it might be they're going to
destroy all these things
now going after obama because of uh
immigration
that one doesn't surprise me either they
could also go after
obama for drone strikes and wars
and all sorts of other things but i
really thought they were going to get
them on the on the gay thing
before the immigration thing but look
these are the rules that you people have
set up
and you know the unfortunate part is
that obama i think does a very
sort of neither here nor their game
which is sort of similar to what bill
maher does
and by the way i would include both of
them in not crazy bananas
identity politics leftism right they're
both sort of sane liberals
obviously obama is way too big
government and i think he plays
he plays you know way too close to the
identity politics stuff so
i'm not i'm not letting him off the hook
there um but
these are the rules you guys have set up
and i guess that school which and then
the idea that they're going to change
thomas jefferson the founder one of the
founders of the united states i've told
you guys this story a million times but
i've been to his house
in virginia monticello which is
basically a museum now and you take a
tour
and the guy yes he owns slaves and he
was also writing the laws to free the
slaves and we're all just people of our
own time
and if you all want to be judged by
history the second
that the future says now we got to
change on something we're all
they're going to take us all out and
they're going to burn all of our graves
and everything else
and when you go on the tour at
monticello jefferson's estate
they spend i would say a highly
disproportionate amount of time talking
about slavery you could talk about his
inventions
you could talk about all of the things
he did in land surveying and building a
country
and all the great ideas that he put
forth right
and they do spend some time on that but
i'd say they spend about 75 80 percent
of the time talking
exclusively about slavery but i guess we
should burn down monticello burn down
obama library yada yada all right guys
let's roll into some q a
uh stephen says should we be concerned
about all this talk of covid passports
yes
yes and yes uh this is deeply dangerous
look
kovitt has over a 99 point i think
six percent recovery rate we know that
the people who got
sick and died most of them had
co-morbidities they were obese and had
diabetes that's not diminishing
their loss it's just a fact virtually no
young people children you know
school-aged children have died
in 10 states i think they reported zero
deaths from
young children but in some i think we
did a cut we covered this a day or two
ago
or i ran some numbers on you guys but
maybe michael can pull him up while i'm
talking
that it was something like point zero
percent to point
one six percent of young children
uh actually got sick and died okay and
and their things happen
in the world right like things bad
things happen that's not to diminish any
of it
the point is should we be concerned that
that a year ago we were told two weeks
to flatten the curve and remember
because this is the part they really
want you to forget we all did it
there was no pushback the crazy
libertarians
the scary conservatives nobody pushed
back we all did it
and they saw how easily we acquiesced
and then they just took and took and
took and took
yesterday i covered how finally i
believe in a day or two in los angeles
restaurants will be able to open at 50
capacity it's almost impossible at a
hundred percent capacity to run a
successful restaurant
so their continued destruction of our
economy and everything else
but the passport the idea well first off
if it's government mandated meaning you
cannot
get on a you know do it you can't go
into a federal building
or you can't engage in commerce or
something like that then that's deeply
dangerous it's deeply dangerous right
like
it's just let's just mark people how
about a number on their arm would that
be good enough for you guys like it's
just dangerous but what i think they're
going to do is outsource it to
corporations first so to go to
a concert to maybe open a bank account
to do
a whole bunch of weird things they're
going to outsource it but it'll sort of
be it won't be the government right but
it'll
kind of be the government because the
government and the corporations are kind
of in bed together
and that's that uh i got some updated
numbers on the
on the kids here we do things on the fly
0.07
of covid deaths have been children and
.01
percent have died that's from aap
i mean that's just absolutely incredible
so again these are older people
who now are vaccinated i mean the other
thing is that the vax people
seem like the anti-vaxxers right now
because biden's been vaccinated kamala's
been vaccinated
right like why are they still wearing
masks it's all
theater and craziness i i hope you can
see it at this point i really do
luna says america seems fragmented
beyond repair do you think it can still
remain
intact seems to have already broken
apart internally
you know i think the tough part of this
is in a weird way
something good is happening here and i
know it's hard to see but
we were set up you know guys like that
scary thomas jefferson who we should get
his name off all the schools
the united states was set up by the
founders to be a federalist system so
that the states could do most of the
stuff now we've outsourced almost all of
that to the federal government
and the federal government just spends
and spends and spends and when a state
like california here
destroys its own economy the federal
government comes in and bails them out
and as i've said before if i was the
average guy in texas or florida
who was paying low taxes i had voted in
the right people and everything else and
then i suddenly realized but wait a
minute
they're given 500 billion dollars or
whatever it is to california which
destroyed themselves i'd be kind of
pissed
that being said the fact that people are
are actually doing what you're supposed
to do
in america right now which is moved to
places um
that are more in line with your values
how you want the government
to react how you want schools to be the
type of community you want to live in
and
basically the type of people you want to
be around i think that's good
i think we have major problems ahead of
us like what what are the unifying
factors
what do we believe anymore i mean this
is one of the things that the woke
the woksters have done so effectively
they've in essence destroyed our ability
to just fundamentally like if you think
back to politics just think back to
politics 10 years ago 15 years ago
if you you had conservatives and you had
liberals and they argued about tax rates
and they argued about abortion and they
argued about foreign policy
but there wasn't this fundamental
argument of like is america
fundamentally evil should we upend
the entire capitalist democratic
enterprise for something else
the workstars have ushered that in and i
don't know that there's enough
good people who are brave and strong to
stand up against it i
i see some people i'm doing what i can i
think a lot of people try to do it in
their own lives and maybe that's
really the only way it can be done but
between the the corporate mainstream
media and the
and the democratic party which are a you
know just like an evil
incarnate now tied together and just lie
to us about everything
uh i think the best thing that you can
do at least at the moment
is is live around people at the local
level that
that are more in line with your values
and and we'll see can this thing hold
i mean look if half the people if the
workstars keep multiplying like gremlins
being thrown into water
well then if half the people think this
thing is bad
fundamentally bad and they keep wanting
to let more and more people in
to tell them how bad it is which is very
odd to me
if something was so horrible you'd be
like get get out let's go
um well then we got a real problem on
our hands so i'm not really sure but as
you guys know
i am a world weary optimist and i really
do believe we can fix this it's just
gonna
it's gonna take a little work guys uh
storm says it's easy to rag on people
you don't like but hard to give
praise when deserved do you foresee
anything good coming out of the current
administration
god uh no
i mean i'll really try to rack my brain
right now like
i don't what like what you know this was
this was the faustian bargain that the
good decent liberals made they thought
if we could just get rid of trump that
just removing that monster
will make things calm down like that was
what i heard from people it wasn't about
the policies
it wasn't any of those kind of things it
was just like let's just remove trump
and then things could we can breathe a
little
we'll be able to fight them back a
little bit more like it'll be a little
bit calmer
it's like do you think anything's calmer
right now do you think anything
feels better like it feels faker i would
say it definitely feels faker they've
been able to
you know sort of have this umbrella on
top of everybody where you can't
really see the truth but you know the
george floyd murder trial is happening
right now in minneapolis and i'm pretty
sure there's going to be massive riots
and that's exactly what
the the woksters and the media want and
really the democrats that's what they
want
i don't think that's like a real
over-the-top statement to say that sort
of thing
so do i see anything good coming out of
this administration look they've put
critical race theory back
into the institutions they're they're
doing all the woke stuff we all get that
um i think they're reversing you know
we're trying to get back into the paris
climate accords and doing reversing a
lot of the
the huge wins that the trump
administration had internationally
especially in the middle east like
there's just like a lot
of weird stuff so is there anything good
coming out of this
i guess if there's a couple random
democrats out there that feel
a little bit better and are maybe being
a little bit nicer at the moment i guess
that would be but i don't know who those
people are so
i'm i don't know i i will try i will try
actually i would love to know
your answers on this guys please in the
comment section below
uh or if you really want me to see it
join us at reubenreport.locals.com
but let me know like what do you think
what is good what policy
you know with a two trillion dollar
spending bill raising taxes on everybody
the border surge like do you think
they're doing anything better with kovid
like
what i really would love to know i
honestly just don't know
uh sally says which influential lefty
would you love to see red pill
i mean the obvious answer is bill maher
it's like i and i know that the bill
maher people are watching this show i
know you guys watch it's okay
it's cool look bill is obviously been
red pill he is a free he's a libertarian
he wants to smoke pot
and probably bang hookers and enjoy
himself and that's all fine he's great
on
free speech bill's problem is that he
has been in hollywood forever and i
would gladly discuss this with you bill
or bill's people that are watching he's
been in hollywood forever he's been
fighting for the democrats and the left
forever he donated a million dollars to
uh to barack obama's campaign to stop
scary mitt romney remember that when
mitt romney
had a binder full of women he hates
women um he went all in on the democrats
and his audience is so lefty
that i think he's afraid of actually
dare i say making the move that i and
many
other sane lefties have made which is it
doesn't mean you're a republican i don't
consider myself a republican
but i'm certainly not a democrat and
he's there he's
there because he gets it on what they're
doing to education
he just repeats all the things that i've
been saying for the last couple years on
his show all the time right
and even when he had ben shapiro on it
was fairly obvious that he agreed with
ben on a lot of stuff and we had jordan
peterson on
it was obviously obvious that he agreed
with him on that and even just the other
night we just played the clip a day or
two ago
um when heidi heitkamp the former
senator from south dakota
called gina carano a nazi he pushed back
on that even though he wasn't even sure
what he was talking about
but i would love to see him be red pill
because i think he as i said yesterday
he's sort of the airlock
for the mainstream liberals that can't
quite get what's going on the ones that
don't watch youtuber pay attention
to podcasts and it's like man in essence
bill you're a libertarian
which you you love america bill i know
you love america
but your answers seem to still all be
that the democrats
are somehow better and the republicans
are racist
my final point on this rant would be he
had uh adam schiff on
and adam and he's asking adam shift why
are all my friends like joe rogan moving
out of california like are we not
business friendly here
and it's and adam shifts like oh yes we
are business friendly but we're not we
have crazy regulation crazy taxes and a
guy like joe rogan who signed a hundred
million dollar deal which i've heard is
worth way more than a hundred million
dollars
and supported bernie he left california
because of taxes
so so bill you've got to understand if
you keep voting these people in you keep
supporting democrats who then destroy
your state bill i know you live in la
you're seeing the garbage and
homelessness and drug use everywhere so
all right i think i made my point uh
gift of cookies
says what do you feel are the
differences between classical liberals
and libertarians
i get this question probably more than
it's like top three uh when i do live
events
i only did one live event last year but
i will announce something uh momentarily
um in essence i would always say that
the simple version of this because
usually when most people listening if
you're not familiar with all the terms
you go oh dave's a libertarian he
believes in individual rights he wants
low taxes government out of the way
i would say the the true libertarians i
love going to libertarian events
i love talking to libertarians and it
always gets whittled down to should we
have
driver's licenses should we legalize
meth and a whole bunch of other stuff
and there's great intellectual exercises
there and by the way
you can take the libertarian thing
really down that far road and end up as
an ancap and you guys know michael malus
who i call the willy wonka of politics
is one of my favorite guests a good
buddy of mine and i love having that
philosophical debate
i think classical liberalism gives just
enough like the lightest touch of
government
possible to allow the markets to work to
allow people to be free to allow states
to have rights
to allow all of us to be treated equally
and all of those things so
you know one of the things that i used
to say i used to say and this one's it's
starting to change
which is that the state has a role in
public education
i i went to public schools my entire
life including college and i got a good
a pretty good education i'd like to
think but now if you're going to be
infected
by the ideas of critical race there and
everything else then should the state
have any right in that and by the way
that's the state
the libertarians basically don't want
that they want as much school choice as
possible
you know there's this new idea and i had
corey d'angelis and a couple other
people on my show on the panel on friday
where we talked about this
the idea of funding students not systems
because obviously we know that the
teachers unions are way too powerful so
the idea is you would give x amount
to the student and then they could
figure out what school they want to go
to we could do more charter schools and
everything else
by the way the democrats hate charter
schools elizabeth warren's completely
against charter schools
sends her kids to private school but you
know she that's
uh well she's also a fake indian so you
know it's a lot there but in essence i
don't think that there's a major
difference between classical liberals
and libertarians anymore if
if you consider yourself a classical
liberal you're basically
you're right there with libertarians
whatever your little political
disagreements are completely irrelevant
and i would say again you're sort of on
the
you're part of the now widening tent on
the right
glenn says have your views on
christianity changed as your political
views have changed
yeah absolutely well first off i've had
some great christian thinkers and
and catholic thinkers here in in my well
not here in this studio but in my
in my old studio ravi zacharias probably
stands out as as the top one to me
personally but i would say um you know
about two years ago
i went and i spoke at liberty university
which is the largest evangelical college
in the united states founded by jerry
falwell it's run by jerry falwell jr now
or i think he's still running it i'm not
quite sure he had he got into some hot
water too
is what it is um but i spoke at their
invocation their sunday event
in front of 14 000 people
uh oh i'm being told that falwell is now
out at liberty okay
uh but i spoke at their invocation
fourteen thousand people it was it felt
like a true political rally to give you
a sense of what fourteen thousand people
is like
i'm sure many of you have seen the video
or the videos or the pictures i've
posted when i was on tour with jordan
peterson
all over the world we did usually three
to four thousand sea theaters i think
the biggest one we did was about six
thousand five hundred so
fourteen thousand absolutely massive
their sunday uh convocation it's called
and
um and i spoke and they knew i had some
political differences with them i
actually brought it up
and i got a standing ovation and i spent
the rest of the day wandering around
campus and i was taking selfies with
kids and they were coming up to me and
hugging me and wanted to ask questions
and everything else
and whatever differences we had either
philosophically or politically it just
didn't matter
so if you listen to mainstream media
somehow it's the evil christians that
are so mean and the white people and
and you know it's always the
evangelicals are the worst because they
somehow supported trump and blah blah
um i i find christians generally
speaking i find christians to be open
decent warm loving
actually every time i'm in florida i
mean i meet an awful lot of christians
and they're good they're just good
people i don't know that you know
that's a blanket statement at some level
but i so i would say uh
i would say when i've talked to somebody
like ravi zacharias i got a really
um i got a really profound
holistic view of the world that that
encompassed both philosophy and politics
and that's what
i'm interested in or say belief
philosophy and politics so
there you go uh vince says what do you
think will be the breaking point
for woke supremacy i mean this is the
billion dollar question like
what will they do that will eventually
destroy the entire
thing and then will they have destroyed
all of western society at the exact same
time
i mean look if if it's not enough for
somebody like barack obama to realize
that he's in hot water with these people
as per the story that i led with
then i don't know i don't know what it
will be you know
i just retweeted ben shapiro this
morning because you know there's this
whole new meme out there
that we should have equity in sports
meaning equity pay in sports and i
covered the megan rapa now story the
other day and
yes although she is a u.s soccer star
her team did get beat by the under 15
boys team
but that she's not getting paid enough
you know this is a woman who's a star
who has no doubt
tons of money because of endorsements
and everything else but she wants
everybody to think that she's a victim
it's very important so shapiro tweeted
this morning because biden was on
did an espn interview and he was talking
about equal pay
pay equity in sports and he's basically
saying yeah i think we should have it
so okay so if if you guys are into this
and lebron
i'm talking to you directly lebron james
i know you're into the woke thing and i
know you won't criticize china but you
love criticizing the united states well
let's
let's do it i mean don't just say it you
got to show it man
so i don't know what you make you
probably make about a hundred million a
year if you take whatever your contract
is i'm gonna see what he makes per year
i'm guessing his contract is probably 30
million can we check on that uh
i'm guessing about 30 million a year in
the nba plus the endorsements are
pretty bananas let's say he makes about
100 million a year well no nba player
makes anything remotely close to that
let's let's equify the situation right
like let's start splitting it up like
stop just putting saying stuff like get
out there
lebron is on a two-year contract
extension right now so this is just his
nba
contract loan worth 85 million
dollars okay so he's making over 40
million dollars a year that's just
that like think of the shoe contracts
the tv contracts he's in that new movie
like
the crazy the investments all that stuff
i think we need a little equity lebron
don't just tell me how evil america is
and black lives matter and
don't say anything about china like
let's pay the girls let's pay the ladies
man
kevin says you hinted earlier this week
about an upcoming visit to new york
can you reveal more details or is this a
highly classified and top secret recon
mission
all right i will tell this i'm not sure
if i'm supposed to tell it but
don't tell anybody if i tell you guys
right now maybe don't say anything to
anybody
i am going to new york city for a couple
days next week early in the week
uh that greg gutfeld guy my buddy greg
gutfeld
uh who is doing who's really great you
know you know i talk about how bill
maher is sort of the airlock between the
online world and the
and the mainstream world but i do for
all the reasons i just mentioned i think
that's sort of disappearing
i think gutfeld is kind of like right
there he gets internet culture
and yet he is a mainstream fox news guy
but he's right there at that very
interesting sort of you know if you look
at it like this like an a-frame he's
right there and can really get both
sides of it
um anyway he's getting a five night a
week
talk show and on monday it debuts
dave rubin is one of the guests on the
debut
of gutfeld with an exclamation point
that's the name of the show gutfeld
with an exclamation point and then
actually um because as crazy as this
sounds in the year
of this coveted lunacy i actually had
not seen my parents i have not seen my
parents this entire time
because it took a long time for them to
to get vaccines and there were some
other complexities there
so i will finally be seeing my parents i
actually haven't seen my brother and my
sister-in-law
and the kids so i'm going to spend a
couple days with family too maybe i'll
do some videos from new york
and if i just blew the gut felt
surprised i apologize to gutfeld with an
exclamation point
clyde says this is not clyde the dog i
don't think unless he's in the community
too
clyde says are you still working on a
local's bundle where we can subscribe to
multiple sites for a single charge
we absolutely are it's seriously complex
for many many reasons because you need
to get all of the
creators on board like okay if we bundle
you you'll take a little bit less maybe
you'll get a little bit if you help
promote somebody
so there's a couple models that we're
really working through
by the way on the locals community on
friday i posted some
seriously awesome information that we
haven't quite gone public with yet
and thank you guys all for the kind
words on that like some really great
great
stuff is happening and uh i think i'll
announce one more thing in a further
question that we're going to get to in a
moment
trish says do you believe dumping
facebook twitter
instagram is the way to stick it to them
or should we still try our best to
continue to speak truth on these
platforms in relation to the current
population
reach i would say you stay there well
look look what i'm doing i guess i'll
give it to you from my perspective
and i get that not everybody's a content
creator or whatever
but my feeling is i want to be on all of
these platforms as long as i can be on
them while
i build locals that's that's what i
believe the future of the internet is
that
everybody right now we're building these
local communities mostly for creators
but i think everyone deserves and should
have a digital home
online that is theirs the way facebook
was supposed to be that you were
supposed to have a facebook page that
was yours
and in effect you would own it and
control the data
and all of those things but of course
you don't get any of those features with
facebook it's all theirs
what locals is doing is building these
things so it's your video it's your
audio it's your feed it's your
communication all of that stuff
and we help you monetize it and
everything else okay um but at the same
time i do think you have to leverage
those platforms for as long as possible
and i don't want to seed all the ground
that i think is really what your
question is
is like should we get off these things
because we know they're not good we know
they're using our data against us and
all of that
like there's legitimacy there for sure
but if we keep
seeding ground is that just
strengthening the beast i'm not
totally sure what the answer to that is
because you know if enough of us just
left
if enough of us were just like you know
what tomorrow like let everybody
get off facebook tomorrow like in
everyone non-woke
right so that's probably 250 million
americans but let's say we could only
get half of them that's 125 and we can
only get half of them
you know that's uh 70 or whatever no 65
something like that 64.
we could only get half of them and then
30 of them forgot their passwords now we
got 30 minutes well 30 million people
walked
that would be something right and it
would show them that things need to
change but
all that being said i can tell you as
locals is continuing to grow
there is a solution coming not a
solution there are
many solutions coming and i'm just
thrilled that i'm a little piece of it
uh ashland says when will you be doing
live shows again okay so we just found
out this morning
i was supposed to be doing a whole bunch
of live stand-up shows
uh in april but then because of routing
and just some of the rules that were
changing and everything else we decided
to shove it we didn't have enough time
to promote
but i will be doing about six live
stand-up shows all throughout florida in
june probably from like the 10th to the
20th we're trying to get those dates
we'll have them for you
soon i have no doubt that we're going to
sell out every show i'm going to do meet
and greets i'm going to high-five you
i'm going to shake your hands
i will hug a few of you i know a lot of
people want it they always want to touch
me
people can't believe we're real people
they just want to poke or touch or
something
but we'll do all that good stuff maybe
i'll bring some special guests
but i can't wait to to get out there to
sunny fl
kyle says did you win or lose a chess
and if you won
did you cheat so uh if you don't know
what kyle's referring to
um david got a very fancy chessboard he
was away for a couple days at his
brothers and they were playing chess
so he got this really cool modern
chessboard and i posted a picture of it
on the community and i
admitted and this is true i have never
played chess
i'm quite good at checkers quite good at
checkers used to play checkers with my
grandma all the time
she was better than me uh but i've
actually never played chess i have not
played yet the week was pretty hectic
this
this week uh but this weekend i'll
finally have a little time and i will
let you know
how it goes and you know we had one
other question that i think maybe we
dumped about
uh about something about some business
thing that thing about the business
thing all right i'll just
i'll just do it anyway um yes people
uh related to locals and everything else
since i tweeted out last night
uh we are moving locals to miami
that's where everybody is moving the
entire tech world a couple of you asked
some version of this question like
what's going on with locals in miami and
florida and business and all that stuff
i believe you got to put your money
where your mouth is so locals will be
moving
down to miami we are going look there's
tax reasons to do it the entire
silicon valley crew is moving there so
the the network effect and all of that
stuff
it's all blowing up down there so i
actually tweeted it out
uh yesterday because uh anthony
pompliano uh who's an investor and a
bitcoin guy
he had tweeted out something about how
founders should move to miami i was like
all right
seems like the right time to tweet it so
i retweeted him and then the mayor
of uh of miami retweeted me so there's a
lot going on obviously in florida miami
as for other
life decisions uh we'll talk we'll talk
you know what i mean
guys part two of my interview with
janice dean is up right now on youtube
and of course the full episode is up
over at rubinreport.locals.com
uh and i'm incredibly excited tomorrow
uh because we are now in the midst of
passover and about to roll into easter
weekend
i will have bishop robert barron and
rabbi david walpian and we'll talk about
meaning we'll talk about the importance
of stories we'll talk about the
significance of both passover and easter
and probably much more but hopefully not
too much in the political arena
uh that's it for now and uh oh we're
doing a little team
we're doing a little reuben report team
workshop tonight we're all going to be
watching godzilla together with pizza
maybe we'll send a picture all right
have a great day everybody
goodbye